you know there's guys that will [ __ ]
your wife you know these guys that will
move on them say yeah you know look I
don't want to be that guy but you
deserve better than Tom how about
friends in the past do that to your lady
yeah yeah and then I did go straight to
me and tell me yeah I guess we're not
friends huh I thought we were friends
you [ __ ] weasel dude listen I'm
friends with her to [ __ ] you certain
guys like that there's certain guys that
just like I had a friend when I was
growing up who always wanted to [ __ ] the
girlfriends of other guys and then if
those guys broke up with the girl he
would immediately [ __ ] them
my dude he's your friend now she's
[ __ ] she's free she's free no free
market what else call those hyenas were
they prey on the carcass what animal
preys on the carcass they'd scavengers
their scavenger they're waiting they're
just waiting for that breakup that guy
is always around and he's the guy you're
friends with for a while for like a few
years and he acts cool and then the
minute you break up yeah dude he's the
shoulder you cry on it took me a few
years to learn that guy yeah oh [ __ ]
you're not my friend how about the ones
they're supposed to be your friend
that's yeah and they're playing like
they're your friend but really they're
just waiting for a mall yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna be a time yes vulnerable yeah
yeah I always it shows if there's a guy
and a girl together and I'm like or are
you on a date no he's just my friend I'm
like oh [ __ ] who does but some girls
know it and they just keep that guy
around cuz he'll drive them to the mall
and he'll [ __ ] take them to dinner
and we just went out with Mike he's a
sweetie
bee mom Mike is just beating off a
finger up his ass thinking about you and
poor Mike well this fingering is that
yeah I just [ __ ] what
two of them are grabbing the balls like
a bowling ball anger is coming [ __ ] men
are so nasty y'all is so damn mad
angry that's not working out talking
[ __ ] and then she texts him after he
comes looking I was like no we're not
friends
mm-hmm friends